5 g pour cinquième génération ce nouveau
réseau permettra des transferts de
données plus nombreux et plus rapide
en s'appuyant sur de nouvelles
infrastructures le problème principal
avec cette technologie
l'exposition accrue de la population aux
champs électromagnétiques
l'augmentation prévue avec le
déploiement de la 5g du nombre de
sources émettant des champs
électromagnétiques dans de nouvelles
bandes de fréquences nécessite à présent
d'évaluer les effets biologiques ou
sanitaires éventuels qui leur seraient
spécifiquement associés
si la 5g empruntera les mêmes bandes
passantes que ses prédécesseurs la 3g et
la 4g
elle nécessitera aussi l'exploitation de
nouvelles bandes de fréquence est
justement la pénétration des ondes dans
les tissus dépend essentiellement de
leur fréquence plus la fréquence des
ondes électromagnétiques augmente plus
les ondes sont absorbées par les couches
superficielles de la peau
lens s est ainsi confronté à un manque
de données impossible pour elle de
rendre un avis tranché
elle pointe le manque de connaissances
et appelle à effectuer de nouvelles
études
ces évolutions technologiques vont
modifier les modalités d'exposition de
la population et nécessiteront d'adapter
les méthodes de mesure et d'évaluation
le rapport final de l'agencé est attendu
au premier trimestre 2011 21
si les résultats se révéler inquiétant
l'inceste recommandera une modification
des seuils limites d'exposition aux
fréquences de ces réseaux du futur
[Musique]